- He's the fastest player maybe we've
ever seen in the history of the sport.
- This is so weird.
- It's weird.
It's uncomfortable.
- I look through the blinds.
News trucks
were all out in my yard.
♪♪
- Welcome to "Simms & Lefkoe."
The Super Bowl
was on Monday night
and it was spectacular!
Why? Because...
- [In unison] Aaron Rodgers is
the greatest quarterback
we've ever seen.
Kyle Shanahan is our
favorite coach in the NFL.
- And they faced off, 33-30.
- Awesome game.
- And if it ends with
an Aaron Rodgers last drive
to win it
it's a beautiful game.
- It is a beautiful game.
And Aaron Rodgers is amazing,
and doing this on one leg.
And I just would like to remind
everybody out there, you know
their offensive schematics
on Green Bay—
- Very basic.
- OK, very basic.
The talent
on their football team
they're a 6-10 football team
without Aaron Rodgers.
- You said this morning—
- Right.
- That the Niners are more talented
position by position
than the Packers.
And we went through,
and I kind of agree with you.
- Well, it's very close,
nonetheless. If it's
not, you know, if they're not better,
it's at least equal.
But I think
the "G" on the helmet
and No. 12 at quarterback—
- Yes.
- Always fools us
into thinking
"Hey, they're
a Super Bowl contender."
And you can see
that he's gotta do it all.
Second-leading rusher
on his team with one leg.
I mean, that's insane.
- Kyle Shanahan's outfit, though.
- Oh, it's awesome.
- Fantastic.
- It is.
- I've never seen a head coach
wear a flat-brim hat before.
- No.
- And I'm pretty sure
that he was listening
to Lil Wayne during the game.
I mean, the swagu
coming off of Shanahan
Lil Shanahan and Tha Kyle V
was bumpin'.
But is this how
he's always dressed?
- It is always how he's dressed.
He grew up in San Francisco
and Denver.
He's got a little bit
of that skater vibe.
- Yes.
- He goes snowboarding,
doin' all that.
So, yes, that's a very natural
outfit for him.
He's lookin' cool.
- Let's not forget that Simms
has Kyle Shanahan's initials
tattooed on your leg.
- Oh, thanks for bringin'
that up. I appreciate that.
- I don't think a lot of people
have heard that before.
- Good. That's good. Yeah.
I don't think they've
heard it either. Thanks.
- You know what they may
have not have heard of—
- What's that?
- And that needs to change?
- What?
- The linebackers for the Jets.
- Yeah.
- Avery Williamson, Darron Lee—
- Ballers.
- Ballin' out.
- Yeah.
- Both had interceptions
against Andrew Luck
and the Colts this weekend.
They were feelin'
high and mighty
and they wanted
to battle Simms and I
in a little game we call
"Best Football Friends."
- Man, you know my name
with two Rs!
- Ooh!
- Ohh!
- That should be a loss of point.
- That ain't no loss of point.
- Da-ron.
- It's still—Da-ron.
♪♪
- Avery Williamson, Darron Lee.
Speedy linebackers for the Jets.
And we're gonna kick their ass.
- What's up,
Best Football Friend?
- [Laughing]
- You see that? They're just taking it.
- I know. They know. They don't
know what to say right now.
- All talk, man. Y'all talk.
It's all good. It's all right.
- Yeah? You feelin' confident?
- Very.
- I like how he goes,
"Yeah, this is easy."
- Like, "I knew my own number in college."
- You got this.
- Don't say anything.
- On the count of three.
- Go ahead.
- Two, three.
- Ohh!
- [Groaning]
- One off!
- Dang!
- So close,
but yet it doesn't count.
- You're sleepin' on the couch.
- [Laughing]
- Damn.
- Oh, damn.
- You have no chance.
- I mean, none.
It's some stupid name.
- Yes.
- I'm going with his hometown
and putting a "Prep" on the end.
Holland Prep.
- No.
- Abington Friends?
It sounds like a TV show.
Damn. What'd you do last year?
- Oh.
- Hit Smokin' Jay.
- Damn.
- How can you not hit Jay Cutler?
- Ahh!
- Wow.
- Damn, what?!
- Damn, you had a bad year.
- Damn!
- But, see, a quarterback hit
is [$33,000].
- For hitting Jay Cutler.
- Actually—oh my God,
yeah
Both of them
were actually on Jay.
- Really?
- Both of them were on Jay.
- Are you kidding me? $66,000.
- That's a nice Mercedes
you just lost.
- Damn. I know, right?
- You'd have been better off
hittin' him with a Mercedes.
- Man.
- I do know this. Yeah.
Cuz he has a big mouth
And I heard him telling
everybody in the office.
- They saw it on my Instagram.
- Well, you know
I don't go there.
- [Ding]
- We got it right?
- Yeah.
- Childish Gambino.
- What's up?
- You ready? I'm ready.
- Ohh!
- Oh, that's different.
- What'd you have?
- "Best Looking"
and "Most Beautiful."
- That counts. That counts.
- That's the same!
- Apparently, I'm the only one
that believes in rules.
- That's the same.
Point, good guys.
- Wow.
So Nashville was havin'
a down year, huh?
- Right?
- Down year?
Oh, it was a very up year.
- Dude. Hold on a second.
- If he doesn't get this right—
- Oh my gosh.
- I am questioning everything.
- Hold on a second.
- We've gone through this
repeatedly.
-Seems like it's around here.
- [Buzzer]
- You seemed like a December guy.
- You seem like a former friend.
- Ohh!
- Wrong.
- [Imitating buzzer]
- He got it wrong.
- All right, you wanna know
what's even worse?
- Tell them.
- Is I asked him
what his birthday was
before we came in here.
- Yeah.
- Did you?
- We're like, "Just in case!"
- I go, "They might
ask me again."
♪♪
- [Laughing]
- This is so weird.
- This is weird.
This is uncomfortable.
[Whistle]
- Yep.
- You got it? You good?
- Yes, keep going.
- OK.
- No, other side.
- Other side?
- Yes.
- Damn. Damn.
- Yes, there it is.
- All right. Here we go.
- Yep, yep, yep, yep, yep.
- All right. Open up, buddy.
Ooh, that was a good one.
- All right. Put it down.
- Where is it?
- Mouthpiece in the middle.
- Yep, yep, yep.
- Yep. All right.
- No, other way, other way.
- Hold on, hold on.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Catch the ball.
- Ball! No.
- Water, water, water, water.
- Stay here!
- Ball!
- This isn't fair. Ready?
- Ball's coming!
- Catch the ball!
- No! What?!
- All right, I'm gonna tell ya.
I'm gonna tell ya.
Ball's coming.
Catch! Catch!
- Yeah!
- [Laughing]
I gave him good eye black.
- [Coughing]
- My hands were in your mouth.
But that's good. They're clean.
- My bad.
- You have to throw that
into the hoop.
Lefkoe's legs cannot move,
but his arms can.
- I'm nervous.
- I don't know where this is goin'.
All right. Here's the first one.
- Uh-oh.
- Uh-oh is right.
Uh-oh!
- Ohh! Ohh!
- Can't move.
- No, he moved!
- I moved my feet.
- That's all right.
- So you can't move your feet.
- Oh! Nicely done.
- I'm the Calvin Johnson
of hula-hoop planes.
- No.
- Oh, I found the touch!
Watch out!
♪♪
- Don't choke.
- Ohh.
- Damn, bro.
- Woo!
- Nobody comes into our house.
Boom. Four out of five. Woo!
- How you like that?
- It's all right.
- Best of luck. Good luck.
Way to find your touch.
- Thanks, man.
- You should probably do it.
You should probably do it.
- Oh, me?
- Cuz I got the longest arms.
- Oh, you're switchin'?
- Nice and easy.
- Oh, gosh.
- All that air.
- Oh!
- Ooh!
- Uno.
- Ohh!
- There you go. You got it now.
- We got it.
- Yes.
- Oh my God.
- That was it, wasn't it?
- Money.
- You're supposed to be
a meathead linebacker.
You're not supposed to
be able to do this.
- Ooh, he's gettin' cocky.
- One more.
- Game point. What's up?
- Right now it's tied.
- Are you kidding?
♪♪
- Let's go!
- Let's go! Let's go!
- I thought we had it locked up.
- Let's go!
- Ohh.
- Great job.
- Today's winners are
Avery Williamson and Darron Lee.
And as you can tell,
boy, are they humble.
- They are humble.
- Very humble.
♪♪
- "Best Football Friends."
We're 1-2.
- Man.
- And as the coach of our
"Best Football Friends" team
I just appointed myself—
you need to step it up, pal.
- Oh, I need to step it up?
- Yeah.
You gave Avery Williamson
the key to throwing
and you forgot
my birthday again.
- Well, why did we go first
on our home turf?
- Yeah, they should've
gone first.
- They should've gone first.
We run this show.
I'll get your birthday right
one of these days, dude.
- Say it for them.
- May 8.
- We're workin' on it.
We're practicing.
- 1984? Five?
- No.
- Six?
- Yes.
- Oh, '86.
That was a special year.
- Why?
- Phil Simms won a Super Bowl
that year.
- Never heard of him.
All right.
- Overrated.
- So you know what?
Phil was the MVP
of that Super Bowl.
- Yes.
- And the MVPs always
go to the quarterback,
and frankly, we're tired of it.
So we wanna come up
with our top five MVPs
non-quarterback edition.
- I like it.
- And because I like you—
- Yeah.
- I'll let you go first.
No. 5.
- Oh, thanks for liking me.
Uh, No. 5? Tyreek Hill.
First of all, Tyreek Hill,
we have to start putting him
in the conversation
with the Antonio Browns
and Odell Beckham Jrs.
and Julio Joneses
as one of the best receivers
in the sport.
He's the most explosive receiver
He's the guy that can take
a five-yard catch
and go by everybody
for 80-yard touchdowns.
- Yes.
- He's the fastest player
maybe we've ever seen
in the history of the sport.
- Faster than Mike Haynes?
- Well, he's up there
in that conversation with him
and Deion Sanders and Bo.
- Wow.
- Yes, he's a special player.
And he is a weapon that you
really can't always quantify
what he can do to a defense,
because they're always worried
about the 70-yard bomb
over the top.
- I'm gonna go No. 4.
I'm gonna go Melvin Gordon.
- Yeah.
- Talk about breaking tackles.
Every time I turn on
a Chargers game
there's people in his wake
as he steps over and jumps in.
He is second in the NFL
with nine total touchdowns.
He's averaging
over five yards a carry.
And the Chargers
are quietly 4-2.
- Yes.
- And the offense is clicking.
And I think Melvin Gordon
is the piece that's making them
one of the elite teams
in the NFL.
- No. 3, yes.
Captain America, J.J. Watt.
He's back. He's one of the best
defensive players in football.
He's tied for the league
lead in sacks with seven sacks.
He's tied for the league lead
in forced fumbles
with four forced fumbles.
He is awesome.
He's extremely disruptive.
He'd be another guy that
we gotta show some love
and throw him in the mix here.
- Look at the stats.
The Texans defense
is shuttin' people down.
- It is.
- Look at the stats for my man
Khalil Mack.
- Oh, Mack is Khalil-ing it!
- Oh, man.
- You like that?
- So, he's tied with—
eh, it was OK.
- OK.
He's tied with J.J.
for four forced fumbles.
And, really, just look
at the Raiders defense.
- Yes.
- And then look at what he did
for the Bears defense.
- It changed the mantra
of their team.
- No. 1?
- No. 1 is Todd Gurley.
The best running back
in the NFL right now.
I mean, Gurley is leading
the league in yards per game
as far as rushing yards.
He's leading the league
with 11 touchdowns right now.
He's awesome
between the tackles
like we saw against
the Broncos last week.
If there's nothin' there
between the tackles
he can bounce it outside
and run by everybody.
He's great in the pass game
and he is really the guy
that makes that offense work.
Todd Gurley is amazing.
He really is.
I like this list. This is fun.
- All right.
So, these are guys that
probably won't win the MVP
cuz they're not quarterbacks.
And there was a guy
on my favorite team
the Philadelphia Eagles,
who had a performance
that was MVP-worthy
in the Super Bowl.
- Yeah.
- Terrell Owens.
- T.O.
- But it's what happened
a year or two later
that I'll never forget.
- What did you say to Andy
to get kicked out of camp?
♪♪
- I was home from school,
and I was watchin' you.
There was helicopters.
Like, can you take me
to that day, please?
- This was during training camp,
and this particular day
it was the receivers' day
to sign autographs.
Well, so, I had
a groin issue at the time
so I just felt like,
"Let me use this time
to go get myself healthier
in the training room."
We had a bit of a disagreement.
And it was, like,
right in the doorway
of where, you know,
people were—
- A lot of players
and coaches saw it.
- Yeah, and I think some
other people just, you know
listened to the conversation.
- Right, right.
- So, you know, he felt like
I was showin' him up.
And Coach said, "Go home."
"In the meantime," he said,
"Keep yourself in shape while you're at it."
I'm in the house
maybe 20, 25 minutes.
I start hearin' helicopters
or whatever
but I didn't think much of it.
Somebody came
and knocked at the door.
And I looked through the blinds.
News trucks
were all out in my yard.
The helicopters and everybody
was around my house.
I just tried
to have fun with it.
Saw my ab bench,
took it outside.
I was, ya know,
entertaining the reporters
and I was workin' out
at the same time.
Little did anybody know,
I had an earpiece on.
I called my publicist
at the time.
She was listening to every question
that was being asked of me.
And so she told me kind of
what to say, what not to say.
And so I just basically said,
"No comment," or whatever.
- Right.
- So, did you go back and you're like
"Andy, I was keepin' myself in shape."
- Well, yeah. I mean,
at some point
he kinda figured that out.
- T.O.'s the man. Ochocinco's the man.
- Yes.
- And we sat with them
for a long time.
They talked about
how hard it was
for the public to know
who they really were—
- Yeah.
- Cuz the media covered them a certain way.
- And I sit here now
and I look at Odell Beckham Jr.
And I'm hearin' quotes
from John Mara saying
"I wish he'd create headlines
on the field instead of off."
How can he create a headline
on the field—
- Yes!
- When the quarterback can't
throw it more than five yards?
- That is exactly right.
What can he do?
And I'll bring this
to everybody's attention.
I mean, we haven't heard
any reports about Giants players
in the locker room
not liking Odell Beckham Jr.
Those are the things
I listen to.
There's no "anonymous" reports
that locker room's divided
by Odell Beckham Jr.
- Yes.
- We've talked to players.
I've talked to people
with the Giants.
- They love him.
- Odell is loved.
- Would you rather a guy
be so passionate
on the sideline
that he yells at himself
or would you rather a guy
on the sideline sit like this?
Simple question.
- Yeah.
- And if you're at home
sittin' like that—
Simms, do it.
You may have contracted a very
troubling disease called Elitis.
- Ooh, sounds serious.
- It is.
- Yeah.
- Do you blame the O-line for the
Giants' poor start?
Do you believe quarterbacks
should be measured
by completion
percentage?
Have you ever been arrested
for defending Eli Manning’s honor?
If you answered "yes" to any of these questions,
you may be suffering from a disorder known as–
Elitis.
This condition makes otherwise rational fans
believe 37-year-old Eli Manning
is still the answer.
Symptoms of Elitis
include yelling
"2 rings” at co-workers,
and arguing that
17 is actually the perfect amount
of points to score in a football game.
Fortunately, there is a cure for Elitis.
Unfortunately, that cure now plays for the Jets.
So take your medicine, Giants fans.
You got what you wanted.
At least Saquon is fun to watch.
Too bad he can’t throw the ball.
- All right, so thus far
on "Somebody & Lefkoe"
our pickers have done
pretty well: 3-3.
Allie, Ira and Steve.
But we're looking
for somebody special
somebody whose picks won't be,
I don't know, falafel.
Someone whose picks
you could kebab your head to.
I'm looking for a gyro.
And that man is "The Dragon."
So I'm tired of
gettin' bad information
so I'm goin' to a guy
that only produces quality.
Tony Dragonas,
aka "The Dragon."
He breathes fire.
We are at the corner
of 62nd and Madison
and I have an incredible game
for you on Thursday night.
Like, Super Bowl matchup.
Denver-Arizona.
Can you feel the excitement?
- I do. I do.
- Yeah.
- Actually, I think Denver's
gonna beat the Cardinals.
- You think so?
- Yeah.
- Now, here's the deal.
Here's the line.
Denver is favored by 2.5,
so they have to win by 2.5.
Do you think they'll cover that?
- Yes, because offense
of Arizona is not so strong.
- It is not that strong.
- No, no.
They have better offense.
- We'll see if Tony can be my
"gyro" and get this game right.
See what I did?
I combined "gyro" and "hero"?
- [Laughing]
- It was good. Just laugh.
So, Super Steve didn't make it.
- Sorry, Scuba Steve.
See ya next time.
Slimms the Oracle is back,
pickin' Thursday roadies!
- The Dragon has entered.
He's taking Denver minus-2.5
in Arizona.
He doesn't think Arizona's
offense is gonna get it done.
- Ooh!
I'm gonna train this Dragon.
"How to Train Your Dragon,"
and I'm goin' with him!
I'm ridin' The Dragon!
- Wow!
- Yeehaw! I'm ridin' it.
- Awesome.
- I like it.
- I'm doubting that you learned
that from Bill Belichick.
- No.
- But you've learned a lot
from Bill Belichick.
- I have.
- And we wish that other teams
would learn from Belichick, too.
- Please!
- It's a little thing we call
- [In unison] WWBD?
- What Would Belichick Do?
And you've noticed some trends
from him this year
that you think
he zigs when everybody zags.
- Yes. You know
what he did this year?
He drafted a between-the-tackles
running back in the first round.
He drafted a tackle, offensive
tackle in the first round.
I think he's goin',
"I don't think defenses
and defensive coaches
are very good
at tackling anymore.
They're so used
to the spread game.
They're not used to taking on
pulling guards and fullbacks."
And I think we're
slowly seeing New England
get back into two backs,
one tight end.
- Power running.
- Old-school football
like we saw on Sunday night
against the Chiefs.
- So you're saying
during the year
we've had more 400-yard passers
up to this point
than ever before.
- Yep.
- Belichick's goin',
"We're gonna ground-and-pound."
- I think
that's what we're seeing.
- They're takin' on the Bears
this weekend.
Maybe he keeps it running.
But watch the Patriots
this year.
If you notice things they do
that other teams don't do
#WWBD?
Be smarter. Follow the
greatest coach of all time.
- Right.
- For Simms
- Peace out, homies.
- I am the L-E-F-K-O-E.
- Man.
- And it's always been
a pleasure. Enjoy the games.
- That's a lot of words you wrote.
- Ready, set, flip.
- Who'd you say? Khaleesi's husband?
That's the same answer.
- No it's not!
- Oooh!
- Jon Snow is not Khaleesi's husband!
- Let's go!
- Soon to be.
- She's soon to be!
00:17:57,667 --> 00:00:00,000
- Let's go!
- Whoo!